hallo sie hatten angerufen sind sie
schon dort also wir sind hier
so geht das den ganzen Tag der nächste
Käufer meldet sich bei Autohändler
Dennis kosmetschow LKW und Baumaschinen
aus China das Geschäft der Stunde
das ist nicht Stress ich habe mich daran
gewöhnt seit sieben Jahren arbeite ich
schon im Verkauf für mich ein Lebensstil
ein Lebensstil der ordentlich an Fahrt
aufgenommen hat in den letzten Monaten
seit dem russischen Angriff auf die
Ukraine westliche Firmen haben Russland
verlassen auch die Autofirmen gut für
Dennis und seine China Trucks in blago
West von hier aus verkaufte sie in ganz
Russland
am Anfang haben das einige schon
bedauert dass die europäischen Marken
den Markt verlassen haben aber die
Chinesen haben große Anstrengungen und
Geld in die Qualität der Fahrzeuge
gesteckt hier steht jetzt nur noch ein
Teil der Maschine wieder liefern können
denn jeden Tag werden mehrere verkauft
manchmal sind es dutzende an einem Tag
Bruder
wir sind von Moskau in Russlands fernen
Osten geflogen rund acht Flugstunden
nach blago westchens die Stadt mit ihren
225.000 Einwohnern liegt am Ufer des
amour jetzt im März noch in eisstarre
hier kommen sich Russland und China ganz
nah mitten im Fluss die Grenze zwischen
den beiden Großmächten der Krieg in der
Ukraine ist rund 6000 km entfernt doch
auch hier hat die sogenannte
spezialoperation ihre unterstütze
doch die Menschen hier sind vor allem an
guten Geschäften mit China interessiert
so wie die Geschäftsfrau hann aus China
hier in lagovecenz nennen sie alle Tanja
das sei einfacher für die Russen stolz
führt uns die Chefin durch eine riesige
Lagerhalle hier gibt es alles für den
Hausbau Zäune Dämmmaterial Glas
Maschinen Metall alles was ich in
Russland gut verkaufen lässt und fast
alles kommt aus China han lebt schon
seit fast 30 Jahren hier
als der angefangen haben hier Geschäfte
zu machen war das natürlich schwer aber
nach und nach hat sich alles eingespielt
wir arbeiten und keiner stört uns also
ich meine die Steuerbehörden wir
arbeiten ganz normal von ihren Kunden
hört Hand immer wieder dass auch von
hier Männer in die Ukraine geschickt
werden und nicht wiederkommen doch offen
über den Krieg zu reden wäre gefährlich
für han nur so viel Krieg sei schlecht
für alle sagt sie aber die Sanktionen
gegen Russland helfen Ihrem Geschäft
weil Produkte aus China jetzt noch mehr
gefragt sein
gibt da können wir uns nicht beklagen
die Russen haben Erdöl wir brauchen
Erdöl und wir brauchen Gas wir sind mit
den Russen befreundet deshalb helfen wir
uns gegenseitig wir kaufen und verkaufen
und verkaufen darüber haben auch die
beiden Präsidenten hier und Putin in der
letzten Tagen in Moskau viel gesprochen
die Achse Peking Moskau sie steht
Russland und China gemeinsam gegen den
Westen vor allem gegen den gemeinsamen
Feind die USA die Botschaft
bedingungslose Freundschaft und Putin
konnte der Welt zeigen dass Russland
international nicht komplett isoliert
ist China ist schon jetzt Russlands
wichtigster Handelspartner und beide
Seiten wollen noch mehr für Russland
könnte das ein böses Erwachen mit Kater
Stimmung geben warnt der ehemalige
kreml-berater wladislav der mittlerweile
in den USA lebt
Russland kann nichts gewinnen Russland
verliert definitiv wenn wir uns den
Sommer im letzten Jahr ansehen gab es
Momente in denen der Preis für
russisches Gas in Europa als es noch
verkauft wurde zehnmal höher war als das
was China jetzt bezahlt
russland hat natürlich nichts gewonnen
man darf Putin nicht glauben wenn er
sagt die russische Wirtschaft habe sich
erholt das ist eine komplette Lüge aber
China hat gewonnen vielleicht bisher
nicht so viel aber dieses Jahr hat es
Russland sehr stark an sich gebunden und
ist zu einem alternativlosen Käufer für
eine lange Liste von Waren geworden
zurück
hier entstehen im wahrsten Sinne neue
Brücken zwischen Russland und China
diese Autobahnbrücke über den Amur wurde
im letzten Jahr eingeweiht um den Handel
zwischen Russland und China noch
effektiver zu machen den chinesischen
Einfluss sieht man an vielen Ecken der
Stadt Banken merkte oder Restaurants
auch chinesisches Essen gehört hier für
viele zum Alltag die Restaurants sind
beliebte Treffpunkte für Russen und hier
lebende Chinesen lange waren die Grenzen
zu wegen Corona doch jetzt macht China
auf und nicht nur Chefkoch Lyon da freut
sich wenn endlich wieder chinesische
Touristen in die Stadt kommen
wegen des Coronavirus sind in China sehr
viele Menschen krank gewesen jetzt geht
es langsam los dass die Grenzen endlich
wieder öffnen aber bisher kommen nur
wenige Menschen
für Politik interessieren Sie sich hier
nicht so wirklich dazu kann ich nicht
sagen sagt sie den ihr alle nur löschen
Hauptsache ist das Geschäft läuft und
die Gäste sind zufrieden mit dem Essen
aus dem Nachbarland
die Amerikaner und die Russen haben ein
schlechtes Verhältnis aber die
Beziehungen zwischen Russland und China
sind gut wir sind die Geschwister wie
eine Familie
die guten Beziehungen zwischen Russland
und China soll auch dieser Ort
symbolisieren
es ist der Park der Freundschaft mit
Pavillons
Pandas
einem See und der Chinesischen Mauer ein
Stück China in Russland vom mächtigen
Nachbarn wünschen sich die Menschen hier
mehr Unterstützung in allen Bereichen
mit Waffen Technik Kleidung humanitärer
Hilfe so in der Art ich weiß nicht durch
die Armee
auch hier tausende Kilometer entfernt
von der Ukraine befürworten viele was
dort gerade passiert
das war eine erzwungene Maßnahme wenn es
die militärische spezialoperation nicht
gegeben hätte würde es uns würde es
Russland schon nicht mehr geben sie
hätten uns vernichtet wenn meinen sie
Amerika die Europäer die Ukraine die
Nazis
Tina Russland und andere Länder müssen
sich zu einem Block Vereinen wie die
Nato und gegen jene Seite kämpfen und
wir werden siegen
es sind die immer gleichen Stereotypen
der russischen Propaganda die sich in
den Köpfen der Menschen festgesetzt
haben in ganz Russland und auch hier in
Russlands
im Laufe der Jahre haben sich hi und
Putin über 40 Mal getroffen 2018 machten
sie gemeinsam Pfannkuchen für die
Kameras
und probierten Honig aus Russland und
zwar genau den von Tatjana kapustina wir
treffen sie in blago recht Jens dass die
beiden Präsidenten verlaufenden Kameras
ihren Honig probierten katapultierte ihr
Geschäft mit China damals in eine andere
Dimension erzählt sie uns
am nächsten Tag war ich ein Superstar
viele chinesische Käufer wollten dass
wir unseren Honig liefern da war das
französische Fernsehen die Chinesen
Russland die ganze Welt und in dieser
Zeit habe ich den Preis des Produktes
sehr stark erhöht weil das eine
unglaublich gute Werbung war damals
Tatjana hat mit ihrer Familie selbst in
China gelebt alle sprechen Chinesisch
nicht nur Tatjanas Blick geht klar
Richtung Osten nicht nach Europa
Firmen die ihre Waren ins Ausland
exportieren wenden sich jetzt massiv
Richtung China sie können Ihre Sachen
nicht mehr in anderen Ländern verkaufen
also ist China jetzt ihr Hauptpartner um
ihre Sachen zu verkaufen
damit Tatjanas Tochter Mascha Chinesisch
nicht verlernt nimmt sie noch regelmäßig
Unterricht heute hat sie wieder ein paar
neue Worte gelernt und Buchstaben die
sie lange nicht benutzt hat
meine Eltern haben in China gelebt
geboren wurde ich aber in blagoveczensk
wir sind dann nach China gezogen seit
meiner Kindheit bin ich mit Chinesen
zusammen und ich habe Chinesisch gelernt
Chinesisch wird als Sprache immer
wichtiger das merkt auch Lehrerin
Anastasia sie unterrichtet seit sechs
Jahren chinesisch
wenn die Grenzen offen sind können wir
einfach für zwei Tage oder so nach China
gehen um zu entspannen in chinesische
Restaurants zu gehen das ist sehr
einfach für uns aber wenn wir versuchen
nach Europa zu reisen ist das sehr teuer
und es ist einfach sehr weit weg für uns
es dauert ein bis zwei Tage bis wir in
irgendeinem europäischen Land sind
wir sind noch mal bei Geschäftsfrau Hand
auf eine Tasse Tee der kommt wenn ich
überraschend natürlich auch aus China
in der Ecke im Büro direkt wenn man
reinkommt steht nicht zu übersehen ein
Porträt des jungen Wladimir Putin
wir lieben ihn
deshalb haben wir ihn hier aufgestellt
damit ihn alle sehen
das nächste Mal wenn wir kämen würde sie
auch noch ein Bild von Schieder
zustellen der sei auch ein starker
Anführer sagt han
in den Farben Russlands erhält der
Leuchtturm das Ufer des amor wenn es
Abend wird kommen die Menschen gerne an
die Promenade und gucken rüber nach
China auf die stetig wachsende blinkende
Skyline der Nachbarstadt Haie
sie übernehmen unsere Kultur und wir
dementsprechend ihre die Küche die
Sitten und Bräuche mitunter einige
Tradition wir feiern auch ihr
chinesisches Neujahr wir gehen mit ihnen
an die Uferstraße jüngst gab es hier so
eine sehr spektakuläre Vorstellung auf
dem Eis gab es Feuerwerk es war hier
sehr sehr schön die halbe Stadt war hier
auf den Beinen und hat sich das
angesehen
wir haben in Russlands fern im Osten
viele Menschen getroffen für die die
Nähe zu China schon lange Alltag ist
Sorgen macht sich hier keiner im
Gegenteil
wenn der Westen uns nicht mehr will
sagen sie müssen wir eben flexibel sein
und andere Freundschaften pflegen